hier haben sie die probleme die eine
metropole eben hat den offensichtlichen
umgang mit sexualität und drogen dass
sich vergleichbar mit worden
denn
das landesfest hat vier
charakteristische punkte wie es
auszeichnen
das ist natürlich das konkret und hass
das ist aber auch raum für die gäste es
ist der ort des fortschritts und
ausschlaggebender faktor der frankfurter
metropole reiche bürger haben durch
diesen stadtteil geleistet das vorbild
war die architektur von paris dadurch
kann sowas metropolen haft es
zusammengeschlossen ist zustand was ja
vorher in der stadt in die kaiserstraße
ist ja unser berühmteste straße der
boulevard der von dem ort des
fortschritts dem hauptbahnhof direkt in
die stadt führen es ist gebaut um vom
bahnhof in die stadt zu flanieren hier
finden wir auch heute die tollen
restaurants die internationalen firmen
freunde treffen und sehr gut essen
können
ich betone dass ich auch mal gerne mit
dem ort des fortschritts und ich sehe
das heute vor allem gesellschaftlich
unsere gruppierung von den büschen
verschiedenen gruppen sind sehr sehr
klein
die müssen zu operieren
gar nicht gegeneinander hier geben
deshalb sage ich wenn man hier schaut
kann man wirklich das entstehen einer
neuen kultur beobachten
wir haben dreimal so viel besucher pro
nacht als ihr überhaupt ein punkt
das macht ein ganz besonderes flair das
punkt hier die leute kommen immer
hierher zu besuch und fand wieder weg
das ist wie das und das hat sage ich
auch immer das ist das herz der stadt
das rücklicht strahlt halt da kommt zu
hin dass das fällt dir eins album das
ist ja auch so gemeint das bringt ja
auch leute in die stadt und hat konnten
das ist also da und das gehört einfach
dazu das wesen s bahn muss für das ist
es nicht
wir können nicht verschweigen dass wir
im moment probleme haben oft die werden
noch keine lösung ist cragg überfordert
und im moment weil wir die forschung
noch nicht so weit voran gebracht haben
das ist nicht immer schön anzuschauen
mit geben
jetzt auch noch nicht am ende
strengeres forschen weiter unser problem
ist im moment die berichterstatter dass
man sich sehr schnell artikel machen
jemand einfach hier gibt sex und drogen
prostitution so was man sich so darüber
ereifert anstatt in ruhe zu betrachten
was ihre sache
hol
[Musik]